les derniers calculs et hypothèses des
scientifiques pour tenter de détourner
l'astéroïde apophis c'est un gros
caillou de 390 mètres qui pourraient
heurter la terre en 2036 et anéantir
toute civilisation
au stade actuel il n'y a qu'un risque
sur 5000 pour les astronomes c'est un
chiffre très important il envisage une
nouvelle solution
nicolas chateauneuf franck briser une
traînée blanche qui illuminent le ciel
de nouvelle zélande il ya deux semaines
voici comment une météorite se
désintègre dans l'atmosphère un
spectacle qui a lieu assez régulièrement
dessus de nos têtes
chaque année près de 15000 tonnes de
météorites tombent sur terre sous forme
de poussière ou de petits cailloux
métalliques comme cette météorite trouvé
l'année dernière dans les vosges mais
parfois ces cailloux sont un peu plus
gros et leur passage laisse plus de
trace il ya un siècle en sibérie un
astéroïde de quelques mètres de long
ravages est une région de plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres carrés
la dernière menace la voici un astéroïde
de 390 mètres de long qui pourrait bien
un jour croisé l'orbité de la terre en
2029 puis surtout en 2036 avec un risque
de collision sur 5000 cela paraît peu
mais c'est suffisant pour que les
scientifiques se penchent sérieusement
sur des méthodes capables de faire
dévier la trajectoire d'un tel astéroïde
la plus récente envoyé un gros vaisseaux
à sa rencontre avec la gravitation le
vaisseau exercerait une légère force
suffisant pour débouter le météore mais
il existe d'autres méthodes encore plus
étonnante pas vrai l'astéroïde en blanc
ce qui ne serait pas très difficile
parce qu'on n'a pas besoin d'une grosse
couche de peinture et l'astéroïde réagir
est différemment au vent solaire et
aurait un léger déplacement
la dernière fois qu'un énorme astéroïde
s'est écrasé sur terre c'était il ya 65
millions d'années éradiquant sans doute
au passage les dinosaures et une bonne
partie de la vie sur terre